more and more parents are being
reassured by the measures that we are
taking to keep their children safe and
are letting them return to schools and
nurseries if they're eligible to do so
as of this week they're more than 1.6
million children back in our schools if
you're one of those parents I'd like to
say thank you for putting your trust in
us I know many of you have had doubts
and they still do I want you to know
that I treat my responsibilities for
your children with the utmost utmost
seriousness their safety their
well-being is my top priority
in welcoming more children back
we have followed not only the best
scientific advice but also what other
countries have been doing to manage a
successful return for their children and
making sure we do the same here in the
United Kingdom and my last briefing I
told you how it was my intention for all
children to be back in school for
September today I want to give you more
detail about how we're going to make
that happen but before I do I'd like
once more to thank the fantastic school
and college staff their child minders
the nursery workers and carers who are
all making a return possible schools
nurseries and earlier settings have been
welcoming more children back since the
1st of June they've been keeping
children in small consistent groups with
stringent infection control hygiene and
cleaning measures in place to make sure
that they're safe now that infection
rates are falling we can relax these
bubbles and from the 20th of July we can
lift restrictions on early years
settings who will be able to return to
their normal group sizes although other
safety measures must remain in place we
know that keeping contacts to a minimum
is still one of the best
ways to reduce risk of infection and
from this autumn when the whole school
population returns we're asking schools
to make sure that they continue to
minimize contacts this should be done by
distancing where possible and by keeping
classes or year groups separate from one
another we've suggested for instance
this schools may stagger they start and
end of a school day and that they keep
their corridors as free from congestion
as possible
minimizing movement of children we've
issued for guidance on the approach
schools and colleges should take and
they expect them to apply this in a way
that works most effectively for them
their students but also their wider
communities we know that maintaining
distance and bubbles may be more
challenging in schools where children
and young people have special
educational needs and disabilities so
we've issued specific guidance for them
if anyone in a nursery school or college
develops kovat 19 symptoms they can
already be tested but from September
we're going to give all schools and
colleges a limited number of home
testing kits to give to any children or
staff who are unable to get to a testing
center parents expect their children to
be safe in school but they also expect
them to be getting a first-class
education which is why from September
we'll be asking schools to resume a
broad and ambitious curriculum and we
expect exams to be going ahead in the
summer of 2021 we want children to be
getting back to normal and enjoying
school and benefiting from it we all
know that the best place for children to
learn is in school which is why I've
been so determined to get them back
there as soon as we can